let's hand to caleb smith your starter
tonight or today for the diamondbacks
four starts this month and his return to
the rotation and he's been pretty
effective so two quick outs here that'll
bring up tyrone taylor 2-2 pitch and
it's a swing of the miss strike him out
so caleb smith for the one two three
first brandon woodruff and making
starting number 15. the brewers are 10-4
in his first 14 starts rough outing his
last timeout loss to the rockies gave up
five runs in the first inning payoff
pitch to the off hitter and that is
strike three call burn the outside
corner at 97 for out number one caught
the outside corner no doubt about that
but good thing he got the call though
there is paving smith
i think that goes off the foot of
woodruff but thomas is there that'll
work 163 for out number two good job by
adamus to change direction i think he
would have had it up the middle anyway
josh van meter now the hitter one two
struck him out swinging fastball at 98 a
couple of strikeouts for woodruff in the
bottom of the first after one in phoenix
no score
garcia leads off in milwaukee second
against caleb smith
there's the heater upstairs and caleb
gets his second strikeout the shortstop
is william adamus
caleb smith good slider there that's
three consecutive strikeouts two down in
the second sometimes takes him a hitter
or two or three to really get locked
into that strike zone and it looks like
he's getting to that point those scorers
are moved to the top of the third when
we walk peterson plunks wong two on and
two out now for urias now he's a strike
away from stranding two
and there it is maria's caught vote on
the backswing there strikeout and in the
inning that's five strikeouts in three
innings we'll go to the bottom of the
third it's been six up and six down for
the d-backs against woodruff so far here
this afternoon
swinging a mess good curveball from
brandon woodruff he gets the punch out
third strikeout recorded for woodruff
here this afternoon
there's strike three called fastball
right down the middle to away here in
the inning and there's two away for
caleb smith the pitcher the 2-2 swing
and a miss
he actually foul tips it into the glove
of manny pina
woodruff strikes out this side here in
the bottom of the third well we go to
the fourth then he does score tyrone
taylor to lead things off for the crew
tyrone taylor rolls one slowly charging
and not in time there's your first hit
the infield single for tyrone taylor to
open up the fourth
way down on the handle barely able to
get it
into the skin of the dirt but able to
beat it with his good speed here's your
first hit doesn't matter how and just
getting that hit column able to beat it
two on now runners in the corners but
with two out pina popped out his first
time and a fly ball to left
right there is peralta he's got it nice
job by caleb who pounces fist in his
gloves he gets to the third base stag
out go to the bottom of the fourth here
in phoenix brandon woodruff three
perfect innings he's got five strikeouts
he just punched out the side in order
one two three in the third and now josh
rojas
bounce this one off the glove of colton
wong and it is center it's the first
diamondback base runner made that good
sound off josh's bat that time finally
gets one on the barrel headed up the
middle of the field wong almost took a
base hit away with that guy in the tent
and there's two away woodruff retired
the first nine he faced in order singled
the lead off beginning the walk to van
meter with one out the walk to cabrera
with two down and now they're loaded for
christian walker the old one to walker
chopper
charging his adonis fields throws to
first in time and woodruff is out of it
diamondbacks leave the bases loaded here
in the bottom of the fourth inning jace
peters should lead off for the crew here
in the fifth
and peterson sends one into right center
field to the gap and that'll get to the
roll
jace on his way to second
and a leadoff double for peterson here
with the fifth he's been on base twice
leads away from brandon woodruff to try
and move him over
and throw over to second boy peterson he
got yanked down over there
as the ball went into center field yeah
he's going to get third that's about as
easy as it gets yeah it looked like he
was intentional
dental contact over there at second base
just dragging him down he drags him down
it looks like jace kind of bumped into
him first
and here's the hulk tie yeah i don't
know about that one on brandon woodruff
into left center field and it's dana
basic that's going to get peterson
and
home
rbi knock for brandon woodruff the first
run of the game there you go bloody able
to come through the base hit fastball
right down the middle and woodruff hit
it into left center we go to the bottom
of the six milwaukee one d backs nothing
woodruff so far has given up just the
one hit he's walked to he struck outside
josh as a single he's got both d backs
hit so far today van meter the hitter
he's struck out and walked two pitch
here it is again and he strikes out josh
van meter
second out of the inning faces the
cleanup hitter david peralta another 3-2
pitch to david peralta
struck him out looking knee-high
fastball
eight strikeouts for woodruff through
six scoreless innings
a beautiful pitch
and another brilliant performance from
brandon woodruff and the brewers will
have him on the corners with nobody out
and they are in business here in the
seventh with garcia coming to the plate
garcia liner in the left field down to
base hit that will get arias home
rbi number 42 on the year for abi garcia
it's a two-nothing game not wasting any
time was he their first pitch
breaking pitch
and hits it hard in the left army garcia
an rbi single one away brewers have
runners at first and third jackie
bradley jr will be the batter for the
crew here 2-2 pitch
and this is head in the air to center
field
dave and smith camping and catching
tagging is taylor and he's going to
bring it home sacrifice fly for jackie
bradley jr
and the brewers now have a three-nothing
lead and there's one away here's
christian walker
walker hits it high in the air it backs
up taylor at the wall christian walker
gets the d-backs on the board got just
enough of it his third of the year make
it 3-1 that's only the second slider
he's thrown in the game he might not
ever throw another one high fly ball
just over the fence out there at the
little notch and there's two way and
nobody on for steven votes one two pitch
to vote and it's a called third strike
with a nice slider on the inner part of
the plate and he gets vote looking to
end the inning seven strong from brandon
woodruff just the one run aloud we go to
the eighth the back end of this brewer
bullpen this is where you don't want to
be devin williams gets the eighth inning
will lead it off escobar bats in the
pitcher's spot
escobar hits one way up in the air
he jumped on the first one and the
singer that left his pant you knew it
was gone
well he's feeling just fine thanks and
it's a one-run ball game the d-backs
with one out in the eighth inning get
the tie run on base and here is nick
heath activated from triple-a reno today
1-0 pitch runner goes pitch is taken
there's the throw on the money out of
second
[Applause]
that was an absolute rocket down to
second base quick release
right on the money we move to the bottom
of the ninth the brewer brewers looking
to win the series now josh hader gets
the knight hater delivers and
that's it strikeout for hater two
strikeouts in the ninth for hader two
outs bases empty in the knife delivers
and it's popped up
foul territory
will squeeze it on the brewers win it
they take the series
it's another winning road trip and the
first place brewer is in the central
ready for a happy flight back home